so Pete you run vegetables probably one
of the most successful sites on the web
covering technology news how did that
start
so I said Mashable knows 19 I was living
in banker East Scotland's little time I
have a note in there no no but it's a
nice long time we go by 6,000 people
when I was living there but I wanted to
get into technology you know so it's 19
I just come out of high school right and
I knew what the university we're gonna
go well you know so I'd had you know I'd
had kind of like a kind of a troubled
school a little bit of a sick a lot so I
had like low attendance I wanted to get
into it but it wasn't really you know
it's kind of a little bit rebellious as
well right right of being part of it
that helps you in an entrepreneur right
being a little bit of a rebel that's
probably a key part of where you wanna
you know I wanted to do what I was
passionate about and if people said you
know be passionate about this I couldn't
really motivate myself you know to do my
individual subjects but I was really
passionate about writing and technology
so I started doing my own thing on the
side pretty early probably in my early
teens I started you know pretending to
be a grown-up and running for like us so
I'd submit they do a lot of free design
Newton's I could have been but I did a
lot of freelancing for American ones
trying to get my writing skills up
trying to figure out what they're
looking for and I also started doing
some entrepreneurial stuff so then I got
kind of more grandiose ambitions and I
thought well and you're still at this
point seven Tigers okay yeah sixteen
variety but you know by the time I'd
reached about like just turned maybe 19
I started to think well how do I you
know I'm not gonna go to university how
do I build something that actually makes
a difference in the world I was trying
to understand technology I was really
passionate about it I figured maybe
other people wanted were to learn about
the stuff we didn't live in Silicon
Valley I didn't really understand
exactly bit of an outsider being in
Scotland but I kind of turned that to my
advantage
Rome extent because I wrote about things
it wasn't so much about you know this
person's moved from this company to this
company but was here's this new website
here's why it matters to you consumers
the things that it does it's all about
utility it's all about thinking about
the reader first and what are they going
to get out of this so that was
incredibly valuable and it was it was
kind of started
the social networking trend this is this
is two thousand five thousand five so
you were right at the right time at the
right moment as well yeah but it was
just something I was really passionate
about so I started covering social
networks and started getting a lot of
traction there and obviously people were
passionate about what what master was
doing so we got a community going yeah
these tips sent in and people would
would say hey I have this great new site
that you should cover I got a lot of
momentum very quickly and then I signed
up my first advertiser probably probably
took a while probably took like six
months or so were you the sales you were
the salesman I am the writer I went in
the eight to ten posts a day right plus
if you can find you know an hour at
night I would I mean I work probably
18-hour days and this was on the the
biggest problem I have wasn't the length
of the day but it was the time zone so I
was trying to compete with the west
coast right of America right and in
Britain you would have to go to bed at
like 8:00 a.m. because that's their big
night in two rows Cisco so I got these
kind of skewed hours my least favorite
part of the job sleeping during the day
and trying to wake up from work
throughout the night now how many people
are up Mashable's now about 60 60 okay
are they all were you based here in the
US that our main office is in New York
okay we have a smaller office in San
Francisco right and but yeah the story
from there to here is very much just an
ongoing process of hey you know where do
we need to add more people to get to the
next level so we only have unfortunately
a minute or two that's everything I have
three questions I want to let you and
Mashable's strange name what is it what
are the several Nashville comes from the
mashups trends right which people were
actually in the web but not the music
scene right people were combining two
different websites so people would take
Google Maps and Flickr and merge them
together and map all your photos on
Flickr still happening now but we're all
the app store is right right an API is
insurance all about building on a
platform
the next question is success when you
think of the word success what does that
mean for you I mean personally not for
Mashable but what would you how would
how do you could you compare yourself to
her where do you
be well I think success is a process and
it's a journey right and I don't think
you ever get there you always see the
next thing you're excited about making
better last question subject probably
near to your heart and near to my heart
has the internet changed writing in the
sentence or two or less how does it
change in a sentence or two or less what
do you have to do that cuz the Internet
where I've everyone in 140 characters
101 because I want to say okay you want
to get the reach yeah yeah um how is
that how is under brevity is it less
reporting is it more immediacy there's
more there's a lot more first-person for
certain I think the fundamental change
that all this technology is brought
about is a rapid increase in volume okay
because used to be that only selected
people if you've had a printing press
you could publish now everyone can
publish now there's some there's some
value in everything that's being
published even if it might seem
irrelevant you know what you you know
what do you have for breakfast today
might seem completely irrelevant but if
you're a statistician trying to figure
out you know what are the meals being in
across America it's actually incredibly
useful so the trick is curation is to
say well this piece of information is
really really important and the role of
the editor the role of the writer is to
find the stuff the gems because people
don't have any time anymore
so there's a rapid increase in volume
but the role of the edifice still
remains which is to find the best stuff
to make sense of it to know the audience
and to pick the stuff they're going to
want to read